the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free to make a donation or view
additional materials from hundreds of
MIT courses visit MIT opencourseware at
ocw.mit.edu ok so well talk about here
is how to actually understand the
performance of your application and what
are some of the things you can do is
actually improve your performance you're
going to hear more about sort of
automated optimizations compiler
optimizations on Monday there'll be two
talks on that and you'll get some self
specific optimizations that you can do
some cell-specific tricks on Tuesday in
the recitation so here this is meant to
be sort of a more general purpose talk
on how can you debug performance
anomalies and performance problems and
then what are some ways that you can
actually improve the performance where
do you look after you've done your
paralyzation so just to review serve the
key concepts to paralyze parallel ISM
coverage how much parallelism you have
in your application and all of you know
because you all did so you had perfect
scores on the last quiz so that means
you you know you take you to look at
your program you find a parallel parts
and that tells you how much parallelism
that you have if you don't have more
than a certain fraction there's really
nothing else you can do with parallelism
so the rest of the talk will help you
address the question of well where do
you go for the last frontier the
granularity we talked about how the
granularity of your work how much work
are you doing in each processor affect
your load balancing and how it actually
affects your communication costs if you
have a lot of things co-located on soon
processor then you don't have to do a
whole lot of communication across
processors and but if you distribute
things very at a fine finer level than
you're doing a whole lot of
communication so we'll look at the
communication costs again and some
tricks that you can apply to optimize
that and then last thing we had talked
about in lecture and one of the previous
lectures is locality and locality of
communication versus computation and
both of those are critical and so will
will have some examples of
that so just to review the communication
cost model so it flashed up on this on
the screen while ago with this equation
that captures with all the factors that
go into figuring out how much how
expensive is it actually send data from
one processor to the other or this is
this could even apply on a single
machine where processor is talking to
the memory you know loads and stores the
same cost model really applies there and
if you look at how processors you know
uniprocessor tries to improve
communication and some of the things
we've mentioned really early on in the
course for improving communication costs
what we focused on is this overlap there
are things you can do for example
sending fewer messages optimizing the
how you're packing data into your
messages reducing the cost of the
network in terms of the latency using
architecture support increasing the
bandwidth and so on but really the the
biggest impact that you can get is
really just from overlap because you
have direct control over that especially
in parallel programming but let's look
at sort of a small review of you know
what did it mean to overlap so we had
some synchronization point or some point
in the execution and then we sort of get
data and then once the data is arrived
we compute on that data so this could be
a uniprocessor right an SPS CPU issues a
load it goes out to memory memory sends
back data and then the CPU can continue
operating but for the Uni processors can
pipeline as they allow you to have
multiple loads going out to memory right
and so you can get the effect of hiding
or overlapping a lot of that
communication latency but there are
limits to the communication to the to
the pipelining effects rate if a lot if
the work that you're doing is really a
Murtaugh is really equal to the amount
of data that you're fetching then you
have really good overlap so we went over
this in recitation and so we showed you
an example of where pipelining doesn't
have any performance effects and so you
might not want to do it because it
doesn't give you a performance bang for
the complexity you invest in it so you
know if things are really nicely matched
you get good overlap here you won't get
good overlap so used for some reason
should be shifted over one so where else
you look for
performance so there are two kinds of
communication the there's inherent
communication your algorithm and this is
sort of a result of how you actually
partition your data and how you
partition your computation and then
there's sort of artifacts that come up
because of the way you you actually do
the implementation and how you maket to
the architecture so if you have poor
distribution of data across memories
then you might unnecessarily end up
fetching data that you might end up
fetching data that you don't need right
so you might also have done the data
fetches so let's talk about that in more
detail and the way I'm going to do this
is the sort of a draw from wisdom in uni
processors so in your new processor cpu
is communicate with memory and really
conceptually I think that's no different
than multiple processors talking to
multiple processors it's really all
about sort of where the data is flowing
and how to memories are structured so
loads and stores are uniprocessor as
what and what are to distributed
memories so if you think of cell what
would go in those two blanks and you
guesses
I heard the answer there right get input
so DMA get in dma put that's really just
a load in a store it's just doing
instead of loading one particular data
element you're loading a whole chunk of
memory so on a uniprocessor how do you
overlap communication well architectures
the memory system is designed in a way
to exploit to properties that have been
observed in computation spatial locality
and temporal locality and I look at each
one separately so in spatial locality
CPU asked for an ADD deferred data
address a thousand what the memory does
it'll send data address a thousand plus
a whole bunch of other data that's your
neighboring to it so a thousand to a
thousand 64 and really how much data you
actually send you know what what is the
granularity of the block pin it what is
the granularity of them sorry what is
the granularity of you communication
depends on search architecture
parameters so in common architecture is
it's really the block size so if you
have a cache where organization says you
have a block size of 32 words 32 bytes
then this is how much you transfer from
main memory to the caches so this works
well when the cpu actually uses that
data right if i send your 64 data bytes
and i only use one of them then what
have I done I've wasted bandwidth plus I
need to store all that extra data in the
cache so I've wasted my cache capacity
so that's bad you want to avoid it
temporal locality is sort of the
clustering of references in time so if
if you access some particular data
element then what the memory assumes is
you're going to you reuse that data over
and over and over again so it stores in
the cache so your memory hierarchy has
the main memory at the top level and
that's sort of your slowest Mary but the
biggest capacity and then as you get
closer and closer to the processor you
end up with smaller caches these are
local smaller storage but they're faster
and so if you if you reuse data element
and it gets cached at the lowest data
level and so the assumption air is that
you're going to reuse it over and over
and over again and if you do that then
what you've done is you've amortize the
cost of bringing in that data over many
many references and so that that works
out really well
but if you don't reuse that particular
data element over and over again then
you've wasted sort of cash capacity you
still need to fetch the data because the
CPU ask why but you might not have had
to cash it in so that would have created
more space in your cash to have
something else in there that might have
been more useful so in the
multiprocessor case how do you reduce
these artefactual costs in communication
so you you have these zma receives these
DMA gets inputs on the cell or just in
and just message passing you're
exchanging messages and typically you're
sort of communicating over a course or
you know large blocks of data and what
you're usually getting is a continuous
chunk of memory although you could do
some things in software and hardware to
sort of scatter it to gather data from
different memory locations and pack them
into contiguous locations and the reason
you pack them into continuous locations
again to sort of exploit spatial
locality when you store the data locally
so to exploit the spatial locality
characteristics what you want to make
sure is that you're actually going to
have good spatial locality in your
actual computation so you want things
that are iterating over loops with
well-defined indices with indices that
go over very short ranges or they are
very sequential or have fixed striped
patterns or you're not wasting a lot of
the day that it brought in otherwise you
have to essentially just increase your
communication because every fetch is
getting only a small fraction what you
actually need so into into it earlier
should make sense temporal locality says
I brought in some data and so I want to
maximize its utility so if i have any
computation and the parallel system i
might be able to reorder my tasks in a
way that i have explicit control over
the scheduling which stright execute
when then you want to make sure it all a
computation that needs that particular
data happens sort of adjacent in time or
in some short time window so that you
can amortize the costs are those two
concepts clear any questions on this
okay
so you've done all of that you've
paralyze your code you've taken care of
your communication cause you've tried to
reduce as much as possible where else
can you look for performance things just
don't look like they're performing as
well as they could so last frontier is
perhaps single threat performance so I'm
going to talk about that so what is
really a single thread so if you think
of what you're doing with parallel
programming you're taking a bunch of
tasks this is the work that you have to
do and you group them together into
threads or the equivalent of threads and
some threads will run on individual
cores so essentially you have one thread
running on a core and if that
performance goes fast then the overall
execution can also benefit from that so
that's single thread performance so if
you look at sort of timeline here you
have sequential code going on then we
hit some parallel part of the
computation we have multiple executions
going on each one of these is a thread
of execution and really my finish line
depends on who's the longest with thread
who's the slowest one to complete and
that's my that's going to essentially
control my speed up so I can improve
this by doing better load balancing
right if everybody is if i distribute
the work that [ __ ] everybody's doing
equivalent amount of work then I can
shift that finish line earlier in time
and that can work reasonably well and so
we talked about load balancing before
but you can also make execution on each
processor faster you know if each one of
these threads finishes faster or I've
done the load balancing and now i can
even squeeze out more performance by
shrinking each one of those lines then i
can get performance improvements there
as well so that's improving single
thread performance but how do we
actually understand what's going on how
do I know where to optimize how do I
know how long each thread is taking how
do I know how long my program is taking
where the problems and so there are
performance monitoring tools that are
designed to sort of help you do that so
what's the the sort of most
coarse-grained way of figuring out how
long your program took you have some
sample piece of code shown over here you
might compile it and then you might just
use time you know standard UNIX command
sort of say run this run this program
and tell me how much time it
took to run so you get something alpha
back from time it says you took about
two seconds of user time this is the
actual code you took some small amount
of time and system code and this is your
overall execution is how much of the
processor you actually use so a
ninety-five percent utilization then you
might apply some optimizations so here
we'll use the compiler will change the
optimization level compile the same code
running we'll see Wow performance
improved so we increase 99% utilization
Maya running time went down by a small
chunk but did we really learn anything
about what's going on here there's some
code going on there's loop here there's
a loop here there are some functions
with some more loops so where is the
actual computation time going so how
would I actually go about understanding
this so what are some tricks you might
have used and trying to figure out how
long something took in your computation
say that ladder
for example certain stuff the timer
right so you might have a timer your
cord time here you compute and then you
stop the timer and then you might print
out or record how long that particular
block of code took and you might have a
histogram of them and then you might
analyze a histogram to find out the
distribution and you might repeat this
over and over again for many different
loops or many different parts of the
code and if you have an idea of you have
preconceived notion of where the problem
is and you instrument that and see if
your hypothesis is correct and that can
help you sort of identify the problems
but increasingly you can actually get
more accurate measurements so in the
previous routine you know you're using
the time we were looking at that sort of
how much time has last in seconds or in
small increments but you can actually
use Hardware counters today to actually
measure clock cycles clock ticks and
that might be more useful and actually
it's more useful because you can measure
a lot more events than just clock ticks
and the counters in in modern
architectures are really specialized
registers that count up events and then
you can go in there and sort of probe it
and ask what is the value in this
register and you can use that as part of
your performance tuning and you use them
much in the same way as you would have
done to sort of start a regular timer or
stop or stop a regular timer there are
specialized libraries that run
unfortunately these are very
architecture specific at this point
there's not really a common standard
that says grab a timer each different
architecture now in a uniform way
although that's getting better with some
standards coming up from and I'll talk
about that in just a few slides and you
can use this a for example measure your
communication to computation cost so you
can wrap your DMA get and dma put by
timer calls and you can measure your
actual work by timer calls and figure
out how much overlap can you get from
overlapping communication and
communicate communication and
computation and is that really
worthwhile to do pipelining but this
really requires manual changes to your
code right you have to go in there and
insert the timers you have to have maybe
an idea of where the problem is and you
have the Heisenberg effect if you have a
loop and
you want to measure code within the loop
because you have a nested loop inside of
that then now you're affecting the
performance of the outer loop that can
be problematic right so the hype is a
bigger effect says you can't really make
an accurate measurement on the thing
you're inspecting so there's a slightly
better approach dynamic profiling and
dynamic profiling is really there's an
event-based profiling and time-based
profiling conceptually they do the same
thing what's going on here is your
program is running and you're going to
say I'm interested in events such as
cache misses whenever n number of cache
misses happen let's say a thousand let
me know so you get an interrupt whenever
a thousand cache misses happen and then
you can update a counter or use that to
sort of trigger some optimizations or
analysis so this works really nicely
because you don't have to touch your
code you essentially run your program as
you normally do was just one
modification and include sort of running
the dynamic profiler as well as your
actual computation it supports multiple
languages because all it does it just
takes your binary so you can program in
any language any programming model and
it's getting it's quite efficient to
actually use these dynamic profiling
tools and the same sampling frequencies
are reasonably small you can make them
reasonably small and still have it be
efficient so some counter examples clock
cycles so you can measure clock ticks
pipeline stalls this might be
interesting if you're doing sort of you
want to optimize your instruction
schedule you actually see it as a nurse
cetacean next week cache hits cache
misses you can get an idea of how bad
your cache performance is and how much
time you're spending in the memory
system number of instructions load
stores floating-point ops and so on and
then you can derive some useful measures
from that right so I can get an idea of
processor utilization you divide cycles
by time and that gives me utilization I
can derive some other things maybe some
similar more interesting things like I
remember traffic so how much data am I
actually sending between CPU and the
processor or how much data am i
communicating from one processor to the
other so I can just grab the counters
for a number of loads and number of
stores figure out what the cache line
size is usually those are documented
order
operation tools you can run to get that
value and you figure out movie traffic
another one would be bandwidth consumed
so bandwidth is memory traffic per
second so how would you measure that
okay it's just a traffic / the wall
clock time there are some others that
you can calculate so these can be really
useful in helping you figure out where
are the things you should go focus focus
on I'm going to show you some examples
the way these tools work is you have the
application source code you compile it
down to the binary you take your binary
and you run it and then that can
generate some profile that's stored sort
of locally on your disk and then you can
take that profile and analyze it by some
sort of interpreter and in some cases
you can actually analyze binary as well
and we annotate your source code and
that can actually be very useful because
it will tell you this particular line of
your code is the one where you're
spending most of your time computing so
some tools if any of you use these tools
anybody use G pro for example ok good so
you might have an idea of how these
could be used there are others hpc
toolkit which I commonly use from rice
Pappy is very common because it has a
very nice interface for grabbing all
kinds of counters vtune from Intel and
there's others that work in different
ways so there are binary instrumentals
that do the same things and do it
slightly more efficiently and actually
give you the ability to compile your
code at runtime and optimize it taking
advantage of the profiling information
you've collected so here's a sample of
running G prop G prof should be
available on any Linux system which is
even available on cygwin if you cygwin
I've compiled some code this is impact
to decode or reference implementation I
specify some parameters to run it and
here I add this dash our flag which says
use a particular kind of inverse dct
that's floating point precise it uses
double precision for the floating-point
computations in GCT inverse dct rather
and so you can see that's actually where
most of the time is being spent in the
computation so here's a time / function
so each row represents a function
cumulative so this is the time the sorry
this is the percent of the time this is
the actual time in seconds how many
times I actually call this function and
some other useful things so the second
function that's used here that happens
is MPEG intra block the ocean decoding
and here you're doing some spatial
decomposition restoring spatial pictures
about 5% so if you were to optimize this
particular code where would you go look
ok you would look in the reference DCT
so MPEG has two versions of DCT one
that's a that uses floating point
another that just uses some numerical
tricks to operate over integers for a
loss of precision but they find that
acceptable as part of as part of this
application so if you use so you omit
the our flag it actually uses a
different function for doing the DCT and
you now you see the distribution of
where the time is spent in your
computation changes so now there's a new
function that's that's become the
bottleneck hands for called form
component prediction and then idct
column which actually is the main
replacement of the previous code this
one is now about a third of the actual
computation so this could be useful
because you can g prof your application
figure out where the bottlenecks are in
terms of performance and you might go in
there and tweak the algorithm completely
you might go in there and sort of look
at some problems that might be sort of
implementation bugs or performance bugs
and be able to fix those any questions
on on that you can do a sort of more
accurate things so g prof largely uses
one mechanism hpc toolkit uses the
performance counters to actually give
you more finer grade measurements if you
want them so in the HPC toolkit you run
your program in the same way you have
mpeg-2 decode dash dash just says this
is where the parameters are to impact to
decode following that dash dash and you
can add some parameters in there it's a
these are counters I'm interested in
measuring so the first one is total
cycles the second one is the l1 so
primary cash load mrs. and then you
might want to count floating point
instructions and a total instructions so
as you run your program you actually get
a profiling output and then you can
process that file and it'll spit out
some summaries for you so I'll tell you
this is the total number of cycles 698
samples which is frequency so if you
multiply the two together you get an
idea of how many cycles your computation
took how many load data mrs. there's 27
samples at this frequency so remember
what's going on here is the counter is
measuring events and when the event
reaches a particular threshold it lets
you know so here the sampling presh hold
is 32,000 and so whenever 32,000
floating point instructions occur you
get a sample so you're just counting how
many interrupts you're getting on how
many samples so you multiply the two
together you can get the final counts
and it can do things like gee prof it'll
tell you you know where your time is and
where you spent most of your time
actually breaks it down into your module
so MPEG calls some standard libraries
lipsy i can bring it down by function
without break it down by line number and
you can even annotate your source code
so here's just a simple example that I
used earlier and you can actually each
one of these columns represent one of
the metrics that we measure and you can
see you know most of my time is spent
here thirty-six percent at this
particular statement so I can be very
useful you can go in there and say I
want to do sind ization I can maybe
reduce this overhead in some way to get
a better performance any questions on
that yep
I don't know yeah unfortunately I don't
know the answer to there's a some nice
gooeys for some of these tools so v2 and
has a nice interface I use each PC
viewer so i just i use HPC toolkit which
provides HPC viewer so I just grabbed
the screenshot from what orioles on this
and you know you have your source code
it shows you some of the same
information i had on previous slide
better in a nicer graphical format ok so
now i have all this information how do i
actually improve the performance if you
look at what is the performance time on
a uniprocessor it's time spent computing
plus the time spent waiting for data or
waiting for some other things to
complete and you have instruction level
parallelism which is really critical for
uni processors and architects of sort of
spent you know massive amounts of
efforts in providing multiple functional
units deeply pipeline the instruction
pipeline doing things like speculation
prediction to keep that instruction
level parallelism number high so you can
get really good performance and you can
do things like looking at the assembly
code and reordering instructions to
avoid instruction hazards in the
pipeline you might sort of look at a
register allocation but that's really
very low hanging fruit very you know you
have to reach really high to grab that
kind of fruit and you'll actually
unfortunately get to experience that as
part of the next recitation so apologies
in advance but you'll see that I'm not
going to talk about that instead I'm
going to focus about some things that
are perhaps lower hanging fruit so data
level parallelism so we've used simdi
and in some of the recitations and sort
of giving you a short example of that
here I'm going to talk about how you
actually get data level parallelism or
how do you actually find the simdi in
your computation so you can get that
added advantage some nice things about
data level parallelism in the form of
short vector instructions is that the
hardware I really become simpler to
issue one instruction and that same
instruction operates over multiple data
elements and you know you get better
instruction bandwidth I just have to
fetch one instruction
and if my vector length is 10 then that
effectively those 10 instructions for me
the architecture can get simpler reduces
the complexity so it has some nice nice
advantages the other thing to go after
is the memory hierarchy and this is
because of sort of that speed gap that
we showed earlier on the course between
memory speeds and processor speeds and
if you optimize the performance usually
you know the one percent performance in
your cache miss rate gives you a some
significant performance improvement in
your overall execution so you want to
sort of go after that because that's
sort of the biggest beast in the room so
so it brief overview simdi and then sort
of some detailed examples as to how you
actually go about extracting short
vector instructions so here we have an
example of scalar code we're iterating
in a loop from 12 from 0 to N and we're
just doing adding some array elements a
to b and storing a result in c so in a
scalar mode we just have one add each
value of a and b is one register we add
those together we write the value to it
to a separate register and the vector
mode we can pack multiple data elements
so here let's assume our vector length
is 4 I can pack four of these data
values into one vector register you pack
four of these data elements into another
vector register and now my single vector
instruction has the effect of doing for
ads at the same time and it can store
results into four elements of C any
questions on that
no we'll get to that so what would you
know let's look at those sort of give
you a more level lower level feel for
this same code I've just shown a data
dependence graph I'm admitted I've
admitted things like the loads and store
the increment of the loop and the branch
just focusing on the main computation so
have two loads one brings a sieve I the
other brings peace of I I do the ad and
I get C sub I and then I can store that
so that might be sort of a generic op
code sequence that you have and if
you're scheduling net then you know in
the first slot I can do those two loads
in parallel slight second cycle I can do
the ad third cycle I could do the store
I can further improve this performance
if you took 6035 you might see software
pipelining you can actually overlap some
of these operations not really that
important here so what would the sort of
the cycle the schedule look like on a
cycle by cycle basis if this was the
vector op codes well oh sorry in the in
the scalar case you have n iterations
right each iteration stating three
cycles so that's your overall execution
on time n times three cycles in the
vector case each load is bringing you
for data element so eighth of I to a sub
I plus three similarly for B and then
you add those together so the schedule
will look essentially the same the op
codes are different and here what should
your overall execution time be well what
I've done is each iteration is now doing
four vector for additions for me so if
you notice the loop bounds have changed
instead of going from I to n by
increments of 1 now I'm going by
increments of 4 so overall instead of
having n iterations I can get by with n
over 4 iterations that make sense so
what would my speed up be in this case
for right so you can get more and more
speed up if your vector length is longer
right because then I can cut down on
number of iterations that I need and
depending on the length of my vector
register and the data types that I have
that effectively gives me different
kinds of vector length for different
data types so you saw on cell you have
128 bit registers and you can pack those
with bites characters bytes shorts
integers floating float floats or
doubles and so each one of those gives
you different kinds of a different
vector length and simdi is really now
smv extensions are increasingly popular
available a lot of ISAs you know em at
the altar of x MMX sse available a lot
of x86 machines and of course in cell in
fact on the SPU all your instructions
are simply instructions and when you're
doing a scale of instruction you're
actually using just one one chunk of
your vector register and your vector
pipeline so how do you actually use
these in the instructions unfortunately
you know its library calls or using an
inline assembly or using intrinsic and
you'll get hands-on experience with this
with cells so you might you know
complain about that when you when you
actually do it compiler technology is
actually getting better and you'll see
that one of the reasons we're using
Excel c compiler is because it has these
vector data types which also latest
versions of GCC have that will allow you
to sort of express data types as vector
data types and the compiler can more
easily or more naturally sort of get to
parallelism for you Cindy parallelism
without your having to go in there and
sort of do it by hand but if you are to
do it by hand or in fact what the
compilers are trying to automate are
different techniques for looking for
where the sindhi parallelism is there's
some work done here about six years ago
by Sam Larson who is now graduated on
super word level parallelism so I'm
going to focus rest of this talk on the
disc concept of civilization because i
think is probably the one that's most
useful for extracting parallelism in
some of
codes that you're doing so this is
really ideal for Cindy where you have
really short vector length you know 228
and what you're looking for a sim
dilation that exists within a base block
so within a code block within a body of
a loop or within some control flow even
and you can uncover this with simple
analysis and this is really sort of has
pushed the boundary on what automatic
compilers can do and some of the work
that's gone on at IBM what they call the
octopi ler has eventually been
transferred to the XL c compiler sort of
do a lot of d techniques that build on
SLP and sort of expand in various ways
to broaden the scope of what you can
automatically paralyzed so here's a sort
of an example of how you might actually
derive some dies ation or opportunities
for invitation so you have some code
let's say you're doing RGB computations
we're just adding the are elements
there's a red green and blue and so this
might be in a loop and what you might
notice is well I can pack the RGB
elements into one register I can pack
these into another register and I can
pack these literals into a third
register and so that gives me a way to
sort of pact data together into Cindy
registers and now I can replace this
scalar code with a way to patent with
instructions that pack the vector
register I can do to complications in
parallel and I can unpack them and we'll
talk about that was a little bit more
illustration in a second any questions
on this ok perhaps the biggest
improvement that you can get from sindh
ization is by looking at adjacent memory
references and rather than doing one
load you can do a vector load which
really gives you a bigger bandwidth to
memory so in this case I have a load
from izr I 1 I 2 and since these memory
locations are contiguous i can replace
them by one vector load that brings in
all these data elements in one shot and
that essentially eliminates three load
instructions which are potentially the
heaviest inter most heavyweight for one
lighter weight instruction because the
advertisers bandwidth
and it exploits things like spatial
locality another one vector I zabal
loops so this is probably one of the
most advanced ways of exploiting
summarization especially in really long
vector code so traditional
supercomputers like the cray and you'll
probably hear some on talk about this in
the next lecture so I have some loop and
I have this particular statement here so
how can I get sim decode out it is
anybody have any ideas
anybody know about loop unrolling okay
so if i unroll this fluke i essentially
that same trick that i had shown earlier
didn't although i didn't quite do it
this way i change the loop bounds from n
to increment from rather than stepping
through one at a time stepping through
four at a time now my de loop body
rather than doing one edition at a time
i'm doing four editions at a time so now
this is very natural for vectorization
right vector load vector load vector
store plus the vector add in the middle
is that two ative so this gives you
another way of sort of extracting
parallelism looking at traditional loop
seeing whether you can actually unroll
in different ways sort of be able to get
that simdi paralyzation and last one
i'll talk about is about partial
vectorization these are might be some
things where you have a mix of
statements so here i have a loop where i
have some load and then i'm doing some
computation here so what could i do here
it's not as symmetric as the other loop
right so you might omit that but could
you do anything about the subtraction ok
so I can unroll this again right and now
there's no dependencies between this
instruction in this instruction right so
I can really move these together and
once I've moved these together then
these loads become contiguous these
loads are contiguous so i can replace
this x vector codes vector equivalents
right so now that vector load brings in
l0 l1 i have the addition that brings in
those two elements in a vector and then
i can do my vector my scalar additions
but what do i do about the value getting
out of this vector register into the
scalar register that i need for the
absolute values so this is where sort of
the benefits versus cost of some ties
ation come in so benefits are great
because you can have you can replace
multiple instructions by one instruction
or you can just cut down the number of
obstructions by specific factor your
vector length load stores can be
replaced by one wide memory operation
and this is probably the biggest
opportunity for a performance
improvement but the cost is you have to
pack data into the vector registers and
you have to unpack it out so you can
have those kinds of communications
between this vector register here in the
value here there's value here and this
value here often you can't simply access
vector values without doing this packing
and unpacking
okay so how do you actually do the
packing unpacking and this is
predominantly where a lot of the
complexity goes so you might notice
whoops screw up animation so the value
of a here is initialized by some
function value of B here isn't a slide
by some function and these might not be
things that I compared that I can some
dyes very easily so what I need to do is
move that value into the first element
of vector register and then move the
second value into the second element of
the vector register so if I have four
way vector register that I have to do
four of these moves and that essentially
is the packing and I can do my vector
computation which is really these two
statements here and then eventually I
have to do my unpacking because I have
to get the values out to do this
operation in this operation so there's
an extraction that has to happen out of
my cindy register but you can amortize
the cost of the packing and unpacking
but just reusing your vector registers
so these are you know like register
allocation techniques so if I've packed
things into a vector register I find all
cases where I can actually reuse that
back to register and I try to find
opportunities for for extra
summarization so in the other case then
you know I pack one then I can reuse
that same vector register so what are
some ways I can look for to amortize the
cost and the interesting thing about
memory operations is while there are
many different ways you can pack scale
of values into a vector register there's
really only one way you can pack bit you
know loads coming in from memory into a
vector register that's because you know
you want the loads to be sequential you
want to explode the spatial locality so
one vector load really gives you
specific ordering and so that really
constrains you in various ways and so
you might bend over backwards in some
cases to actually get your code to be
able to you reuse sort of the wide word
load without having to do too much
packing or unpacking because that'll
start eating into your benefits so a
simple example of how you might find the
super look the SLP parallelism
so the first thing you want to do is
start with sort of the ones that the
instructions that give you the most
benefit so its memory references so here
there are two memory references they
happen to be adjacent so I'm accessing
contiguous memory chunks so I can
paralyze that so it would be my first
step I can do it vector load and that
assignment can become a and B and I can
look for opportunities where I can
propagate the this vector this vector
values in this vector register that's
holding a and B well so the way I do
that is I look for uses of a and B so in
this case there are these two statements
okay so i can look for opportunities to
vectorize that and so in this case both
of these instructions are also vector I
zabal so now I have vector subtraction
and I have new have a vector register
holding new values H&J so I follow that
chain again of where data is flowing so
I find these operations and I can
vectorize that as well
okay so so i end up with a vector I
zabal loop where all my instructions all
my scale instructions are now in Simi
instructions and I can cut down on serve
loop iterations total number of
instructions that I issue but I've made
some implicit assumption here anybody
know what it is yep my collections well
so you can factor down the cost right so
here I vectorized by two so we cut down
the number of iterations by two right so
you could have an odd number of
iterations what do you do but sort of
the remaining iterations you might have
to do scalar code for that what are some
other assumptions maybe it'll be clear
here so in vectorizing this what have I
assumed about sort of relationships
between e-statements I've essentially
reorganize all the statements so it
assumes you know I have this Liberty to
move instructions around yep
right so there's nothing in here that's
changing the values and there's no
dependencies between these statements no
flow dependencies and no other kinds of
constraints that sort of limit this kind
of movement so in real code it's not
actually the case you end up with
patterns of computation where you can
get really nice cases classic cases you
can affect vectorize those really nicely
been in a lot of other codes you have a
mix of vector I zabal code and scalar
code and there's a lot of communication
between the two so the cause is really
quite something significant that you
have to consider so just was as i
mentioned done and somebody's master's
thesis and eventually led to some
additional work that was his PhD thesis
and so in some of the early work what he
did was he looked at a bunch of
benchmarks and looked at how much
available parallelism you have in terms
of this kind of short vector
paralyzation or rather SLP where you're
looking for vector I zabal code within
basic blocks which really differed from
classic way of people looking for
vectorization and your well-structured
loops and doing kinds of transformations
you'll hear about next week and so for
different kinds of vector registers so
these are your vector length so going
from 128 bits to a thousand 24 bits you
can actually reduce a whole lot of
instructions so what I'm showing here is
the percent dynamic instruction
reduction so if i take my baseline
application and just compile in a normal
way and i run it again instruction count
i apply this SLP technique to sort of
find the civilization and then run my
application again user performance
counters account the number of
instructions and I sort of compare the
two you know I can get sixty percent
fifty percent forty percent you know
some cases I can completely eliminate
almost ninety percent or more of the
instructions so it's a lot of
opportunity for sort of performance
improvement that might be sort of
apparent one because i'm reducing the
instruction bandwidth i'm reducing the
amount of space I need in my instruction
cache I fewer instructions so I can fit
more instructions into my instruction
cache you reduce number of branches you
get better bandwidth to memory better
use of the memory bandwidth
and overall you know you can you're
running fewer iterations so you're
getting lots of potential for
performance so actually ran this on the
altivec this was sort of one or earliest
generations altivec which had assembly
instructions didn't have I believe
double float important and I think yeah
a double-precision floating-point so not
all the benchmarks you see on the
previous slide are here only the ones
that could run reasonably accurately
with a single precision floating point
and so what they measure is the actual
speed up doing the simulation versus not
doing a civilization how much
performance you can get and the other
thing takeaway is in some cases where
you have nicely structured loops and
some nice patterns you can get you know
up to a 7 X speed up on on some
benchmarks so what might be the maximum
speed up that you can get it depends on
the vector length so eight for example
on some architectures depending on the
data type there are any questions on
that so as part of the next recitation
you'll actually get an exercise of going
through and sim guising for cell and
what does it actually mean to sim dies
instructions for sale well might take
statements and sort of replace them by
intrinsic functions which eventually map
down to actual assembly op codes that
you'll need so you don't actually have
to program at the assembly level
although in effect you're probably doing
the same thing ok so last thing we'll
talk about today is optimizing for the
memory hierarchy and in addition to the
sort of data level parallelism looking
for performance enhancements in the
memory system gives you the best
opportunities because of sort of this
just this big gap in performance between
memory access Layton sees and what the
CPU efficiency is so exploiting look how
the inner memory system is key so these
concepts of temporal and spatial
locality so let's look at an example so
let's say I have a loop and in this loop
I have some code that's embodied in some
function a some code embodied in some
function B and some code and some
function see the values produced by a
are consumed by
the function B and similarly value is
consumed by B are consumed by I see so
this is sort of a general data flow
graph that you might have for this
function let's say that we can produce
sort of all the data could go into a
small array that then I can communicate
between functions so if i look at my
actual cache size and how the working
set of each of these functions is so
let's say this is my cache size this is
how much how many instructions i can
pack into the cache and looking at the
collective number of instructions in
each one of these functions I sort of
overflow that I have more instructions
that can fit into my cash at any one
time so what does that mean for my
actual cash performance so when i run a
what do I expect the sort of the cache
hit and miss rate behavior to be like so
in the first iteration I'm going to run
I need the instructions for a right I've
never seen a before so I have to fetch
that data from memory and put it in the
cache Saudi a cache miss right okay so
what about be right and as he same thing
okay so now i'm back at the top of my
loop right so if everything fit in the
cache then i would expect a to be a what
right you'll be hit but since I've sort
of give it constrained this problem such
that the where he said doesn't really
fit in the cache what that means is that
I have to fetch some new instructions
for a so let's say I have to fetch all
the instructions for a again so that
leads me to another miss right and now
bringing a again into my cash kicks out
some extra instructions because I need
to make room in a finite memory so I
kick-out be and as you know bring in B
and I end up kicking out C and so you
end up with a pattern where everything
is amiss so this is a problem because
you know the way this loop is structured
collectively I just can't pack all those
instructors into their cash so I end up
taking bad end up taking a lot of cache
misses and that's bad for performance
but I can look at an alternative way of
doing this loop I can split up this loop
in 23 wherein one
loop I do all the a instructions and be
in the second loop i do all the bees and
the third loop i do all the Seas so now
my working set is really small right so
the instructions for a fit in the cache
instructions for be fit in the cache
instructions for cease fitna cash so
what do I expect for first time I see a
and in Miss and then a second time what
it'll be a hit right because I brought
in a I haven't run B or C yet the number
of instructions I need for a is smaller
than what I can fit into the cash so
that's great nothing gets kicked out so
every one of those iterations for a
becomes a hit so it's good I've improved
performance for be I have the same
pattern at first I my CB its miss every
time after that it's a hit and similarly
for see so my cache miss rate goes from
being one everything is amiss to
decreasing to 1 over N where n is
essentially how much I can run the loop
so we call that full scaling because
we've taken sort of blue bow distributed
and we've scaled every one of those
smaller loops to the maximum that we can
get now what about the data so we have
the same example here we saw that the
instruction the instruction working set
is big but what about the data so let's
say in this case I'm sending just a
small amount of data then the behavior
is really good right my data working set
it's a small amount of data that I need
to communicate from A to B a small
amount of data and you need to
communicate from B to C so that's great
no problems with the data cache what
happens in the full scale in case
so yeah not even correct I convenience
community what do you mean it's not
right oh it's not communicating this
yeah it's not at the same time it's just
saying but in fact just assume this is
sequential right so I run a I stole some
I store some data and then when i run be
I grab that data this is some sequential
nothing how do you know that running how
do you know that the transmission is
valid then we could use some global
variable a simple case there's no global
variables all to communicate all the
data that be needs comes from a so if i
run a i produce all the data and that's
all that be neat ok so in the full scale
in case what do i expect to happen for
the data remember in the full scale in
case all the working sets for
instructions are small so they all fit
in the cache but now i'm running a for a
lot longer so i have to store a lot more
data for B and similarly I'm running be
for a lot longer so I have to store a
lot more data for C so what I expect to
happen with the working set here right
structures are so good but the data
might be bad because I've I've run a for
a lot more iterations at one shot so now
i have to buffer all this data for a to
b and similarly I've run be for a long
time so I have to buffer a whole lot of
data for b2c exact clear no no so let's
say every time a runs it produces one
data element so now in this case every
communicate every iteration produces one
day to element that's fine that's clear
here I run a and time so I produce n
data elements right and be lets say
produces one data element so if my cash
can only hold I'll say n by 2 data
elements then there's an overflow so
what that means is not everything is in
the cash and that's bad because the same
reasons we saw for the instructions when
I need those data I have to go out to
memory and get them again so it's extra
communication extra redundancy
I've noticed really just sequential
simple case right I need all the data
from a two run all iterations for be
right and then yeah this goes away right
so let's say this goes away but still be
produces n elements and that overflows
the cash okay so there's a third example
where I don't fully distribute
everything I partially distribute some
other loops so I can fully scale a and B
because I can fit those still I can fit
those instructions in the cache and that
gets me around this problem right
because now a and B are just
communicating one data element but c is
still a problem because i still have to
run be n times in the end before i can
run c so there are n data elements in
flight alright so the data for be still
becomes a problem in terms of its
locality exactly okay so hard any ideas
on how I can approve this
do one or two
to get the data that
so in programs instructions programs
typically have really good instruction
locality just because nature of the way
we run it we have small loops and they
iterate over and over again data is
actually where you spend most of your
time in the memory system it's fetching
data so i didn't actually understand why
you think data is less expensive than
instructions okay so every eight
iteration right right so that assumes
that you have really good spatial
locality right because you assume that I
brought in eight elements and I'm going
to use every one of them so if that's
the case you have really good spatial
locality and that's in fact what you
want it's the same kind of thing that I
showed for the instruction cache first
thing is a mess the rest are hits the
reason data is more expensive you simply
have a lot more data reads then you have
instructions typically you have small
loops you know hundreds of instructions
and they might access really big arrays
that are millions of data references so
that becomes a problem so ideas on how
to improve this yep that's the loop so
what would you do in the smaller loop
something like that okay so in the
nested loop right you have a smaller
loop that has a smaller number of
iterations 264 and you know so 64 might
be just as much as I can buffer for the
data in the cache and then I wrap that
loop with one outer loop that completes
the whole number of iterations so if I
had to do and then I divide n by 64 and
so that can work out really well there
are different kinds of blocking
techniques that you can use on getting
your data to fit into your local store
or enter your cash to exploit sort of
these spatial and temporal properties
question you could do that as well but
the problem was running ABC sequentially
is that if they're all in the same loop
you end up with instructions being bad
that was really this case so even if you
change this number you don't get around
the instructions okay so you're going to
see more optimizations as sort of do
more of these loop tricks you know I
talked about unrolling without really
defining what unrolling is they're going
into a lot of details loop distribution
loop fission some of the things like
Luke tiling loop Hawking I think
someone's going to cover some of these
next week so this was implemented this
was done by another master student at
MIT graduated about two years ago to
sort of show that if you factor in cash
constraints versus ignoring cash
constraints how much performance you can
get this was done in a context of stream
it so in fact some of you might have
recognized sort of A to B to C being
interconnected as pipeline of filters
and we ran it on different processors so
strong on processor is really small in
order processor has no l1 cache in this
particular model that we used that I had
a really long latency to MIT sorry he
had no l2 cache it had really long
latency to memory pentium an x86
processor reasonably fast it had a
complicated memory system and a lot of
memory overlap in terms of references
and
Kenyan processor which had a huge l2
cache at its disposal so you can see is
that lower bars indicate bigger speed
ups and this is normalized run time so
on the processor where you don't
actually have caches to save you and the
memory communication is really expensive
you can get a lot of benefit from doing
the cache aware scaling sort of that
loop nesting to take advantage of
packing instructions into the
instruction cache packing data into data
cache and not having to go out to memory
if you don't need to so you can reduce
run time to about a third of what it was
with this kind of cash optimization on
the Pentium 3 where you have sort of a
cash to help you out you know benefits
are there but you don't get as big a
benefit from to ignoring the cash
constraints versus being aware of the
cache constraints so here you're
actually doing some of the debt that
middle column whereas here we're doing
the third column the cache aware fusion
and in nineteen IAM we really get
noticed no no benefits between the two
yep with the left column peace yeah so
this is uh huh yeah tricky probably
should remember so the left columns are
doing this right and the third column is
doing this right so you want to do this
because the I cash locality is best so
you always want to go to full or maximum
scaling so I'm actually plugging a
little just for the sake of clarity and
here you're actually doing this this
nesting to improve both the instruction
and the data locality okay so you can
get really good performance improvements
so what does that mean for your cell
projects or four cell we'll talk about
that next week of the recitation
yeah well it just means that if you have
cash is to save you and they're really
big caches and they're really efficient
there's really it's you know law of
diminishing returns so that's where
profiling comes in so you look at the
profiling results you look at your cache
misses how many cache misses are you
taking if it's really significant then
you look at ways to improve it if your
cache misses are really low your miss
rate is really load then it doesn't make
sense to spend time and energy focusing
on that good question okay so any other
questions all right so summarizing sort
of the gamut of programming for
performance so you tune the parallelism
first right because if you can't find a
concurrency you're a Modell's law you're
not going to get a whole lot of speed up
but then once you sort of figured out
what the parallelism is and what you
want to do is really get the performance
on each processor the single track
performance to be really good you
shouldn't ignore that so modern
processors are complex you need
instruction level parallelism you need
data level parallelism you need memory
hierarchy optimizations and show you
should consider sort of those
optimizations and here profiling tools
could really help you figure out where
we're the biggest benefits to
performance will come from and you may
have to in fact change everything you
may have to change your algorithm your
data structures your program structure
so in the impact decoder case for
example I showed you that if you change
the flag that says don't use double
precision inverse dct use a sort of a
numerical hack then you can get
performance improvements but you're
changing your algorithm really and you
really want to focus on just the biggest
nugget you know where's the most
performance coming in or where is the
biggest performance problem like that's
the thing you want to optimize so
remember law of diminishing returns
don't spend your time on doing things
that are going to get you anything
significant in return and that's it any
questions
okay are you guys doing with the project
um so one of the one of the added
benefits of the central CBS repositories
I get notifications to when you serve my
things so I know of only two projects
that have been submitting things
regularly so I hope that will pick up
soon okay I guess a few minutes to
finish the quiz and then we'll see you
next week go again